[Music]
[Applause]
morning to you ladies
my name is
[Music]
sanitary bros sanitary bro
hit me up bro
[Music]
i've i when i finish first
this is my house now get out edgar's my
dog
you can have him that's okay so why did
we do that funny little skit in the
beginning jack
because it's important to stay safe
during these times all right no
i don't care about that i meant the
impressions i mean i don't care what i
do
because we're making impression videos
impressions
yes i yours was so good that i forgot
you did it
so you're actually pretty good at
impressions am i yeah
come on don't be humble you're you're
pretty good well every time i turn on a
camera i'm not
okay well we'll see now then okay uh
maybe i'll beat you this is a
competition
now yeah okay we're gonna look at some
pewdiepie
impressions and some jacksepticeye
impressions and we're gonna judge you
yeah that's right if you ever uploaded a
video with either pewdiepie or
jacksepticeye impressions you're
sweating right now yeah
you're ready to be roasted you're gonna
roast out of you
get ready 12 year olds or if your name
is daz games
there's a lot of youtuber impressions so
you must be pretty good um
i apparently like this video i don't
remember liking this video or watching
when was the last time you've liked a
video
uh i like video okay here we go all
right i hope he keeps that hair on
he doesn't look like me so he's already
failed
right right here we go how's it going
my name is
so this is him pirating 2016 pewdiepie
but nothing has changed
it's more like he's a prophet
he just knew how what was gonna happen
yeah jesus christ not that fair off how
long does he go for it
keep it going oh that was the whole
impression
okay it's not funny what do you think
it's not funny i'm not smiling through
the
the match i am can you see the joy in my
eyes what a frame
i thought that was pretty good on a
scale of one to ten it's about a seven
it's too scarily similar i don't like it
he just needed to end on that like
face that you always used to do that
how's it going bro
i can't i've got just side editing in
our faces
[Music]
[Laughter]
i see see that's what you got to do with
an impression though you're either
really good at it so you you impress
people that way or you parody it and
that's what he did
okay because he can't actually do your
voice yeah that's a good that's a good
point he had to mess around with you
oh by the end of this we should do each
other's impression
okay and then you guys judge who did it
better
uh he also did one of you oh let's see
it he did this a while ago but dance
kind of blew up like his channel is
doing
it's pretty big now yeah good for you
dad good for you dad
[Music]
that's how i feel looking at my old
videos now everybody realizes my name is
everybody welcome back to undertale i'm
like shut the up
it's like you know people like you right
you don't have to try so hard
shut up i like how we give you the
thinnest hairline oh my heart bro
ladies my name is jackson five i'm the
jackson five apparently
me according to your ladies my name
is
yeah that's me at the start of every
video i can't even say my own name i
don't even do it anymore robin can
confirm
he has to cut out at least five of them
all the blooper reels that i have
i feel like if you just do that like
that's half your impression
yeah it's so distinct all you have to do
is match the energy level and then you
have
oh okay is that how you do it you're
just like
how quickly can you get it on and off
like do you have to
no don't do that you scare me
it used to be different and then i took
an open pitch up and up and up and then
i hit this note that i hit every single
time oh
it wasn't intended i just got really
annoying damn i respect that you do the
same pitch every time though
yeah like if you do a low pitch everyone
will be like oh he's kind of sad here i
mean it's almost musical isn't it it's a
pewdiepie oh i see you kind of have to
keep it the same
otherwise people are like no go back in
and do it again
how's it going bros my name is
top of the morning to you yeah you're
right i get it
i changed my name legally why can't i
say his name
my name is jackson all right he's doing
a bit now come on you know how to say
jackson today
[Laughter]
top of the morning to your ladies my
name is jax
jacksepticeye septic
honestly if i just messed it up i'd roll
with it yeah i'm cool like that yeah
that's some chad i'm just hippie
dippy cool like that's some charge
did my dude should we jump in between
and do like
okay this one this one doesn't work this
is both 68 000 views and a lot of likes
it kind of looks like a weird mesh of us
yeah this is what our child would look
like
welcome to this video now this is going
to be a very
hey oh my god we're going to give them a
go as well
okay so first on the agenda is the
biggest boy
the biggest boy on youtube has he
started it yet mr pewdiepie i can't tell
hey i mean how's going press my name is
peter pan
hey i mean how's it going bruce manning
i'll see if he gets a pitch right
that's not his normal intro is it yes it
is okay right
we'll give that one a go round one
fight hey i mean how's it going guys but
it
bro it's bros if you're going to make a
youtube impression video how's it going
guys
what's up my dudes cringe dude
you put this out on the internet
stay safe and do this hey
i mean how's it going bruce my name is
god it's so bad it sounds like you doing
an impression of yourself
yeah right trying to do like 2012
pewdiepie
right my god can you can you go back to
that
or is it just lost forever 2012 yeah
how's it going bros my name is
so weird
it's like before i even started making
videos i don't wonder why i did the
laughing one like
how's it going perhaps i don't know
let's go back to the speech coach
yeah he's doing that that makes it more
endearing it opens up the video
immediately
i thought it was like oh it's kind of
friendly to laugh in the beginning like
maybe you're just faking enthusiasm if i
laugh then people will think i'm happy
no no that's not how it worked at all
i remember actually do thinking like
yeah if i force a little happiness then
at least it will make other people happy
i mean it's gonna work it puts you in
that headspace
that's what i thought at least okay all
right can it work are you happy
are you happy you're a big guy oh he did
mark all right should we check out mark
though everyone has a mirror impression
all right i want to hear your mark oh no
i don't know what does he sound like
these days yeah i don't know did you
still do the intro
hello everybody
[Laughter]
and then he stopped doing that and he
changed it
you had an influence on mark hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back
dude that's scary oh spooky i can't
watch it again
it's spooky hello everybody my name is
markiplier
hello everybody my name is markiplier
which one's better leave a comment
i think we're both pretty
i guess we'll find out so what have you
got in there what have you got
marky marcumu
[Music]
that's not the intro i'm just gonna cut
to yours yes please
maybe before mark is that you
no this one this one's going to be quite
hard to do
top of the morning to you ladies my name
is jacksepticeye and welcome back to
okay then what am i doing i'm gonna need
some props
come on into your laddies my name is
jacksepticeye
feel it we're going through this again
what is it
my life's work what an insult
disgusting at least he tried with you
what was that
yeah that was no energy if you got to do
the jacksepticeye you got to do the
energy
yeah it's like ninety percent of the
morning to you ladies my name is
jacksepticeye and welcome back to
you got to feel like the veins in your
head is popping out like
blood is about to splurge out of your
eyes yeah i don't have a personality
i just have my energy that is my
personality
what am i doing oh my god that's not
even that long ago
okay you're so confused i don't know
what i'm saying it looks like you don't
even know why you're doing it
okay this one this one's gonna be quite
hard to do top of the morning to you
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to okay then what am i
saying
i'm gonna need some props come on into
your laddies my name is jacksepticeye
he tries harder well we gotta do this
again what is it
good morning to you ladies my name is
jacksepticeye and welcome back to
the morning to you ladies my name is
james sexton all right i want an actual
impression
why is everybody messing up the intro
i'm trying to be funny
we don't we won't watch your humor we
don't want you to be funny we wanna all
right see if i dubs can do it
whoosh top of the morning to you ladies
jacksepticeye here
today we're gonna play grow home
this is such a cool game i love playing
grow home
you play as a cool guy it's like he's
doing an impression of you
doing me yeah that's weird he's also
he's also doing the uh
generic irish voice as well yeah oh
yeah you don't really talk like that no
no one's ever able to get it right what
is wrong with you plus no one like bro
at home come on
yeah and i guarantee you there's people
in the comments of that video being like
it's so amazing he's so happy all right
we'll see it
congratulations you just played yourself
that's so embarrassing amazing ha
ha i like how everyone looks shocked and
then cringed
a plus effort hey that's pretty good
see hey we just did an item impression
out of that yeah yeah what do you think
about that huh
yeah review that monitor my name's
jacksepticeye and today we're going to
be playing a bit of spider-man
yeah that was pretty good no i like the
spider-man
classic me take
[Applause]
suppose people don't lead into the happy
wheels one more all right
at least he tried you know yeah all
right i'm glad that
because all the impressions of you are
going to be like the super old one
yeah i'm i'm almost at a point now where
all the impressions of me
feel really old and it's not even that
long ago it just
it feels so different than what it is
now what do you
what do you do now nothing yeah i don't
even do my insane i guess i have the
same yeah i don't really
best pewdiepie impression 2013. whoa hey
guys how's it going
that's what's happening boy one two
three four doing another impression
he hasn't started yet
that's pretty good that's pretty damn
good i'm just
just sitting around here because if you
want to you
you can rub my nipples or you can do
other stuff to me if you want is it
being me i'm so confused
that's not that bad actually just just
come over to me and
touch me any way you want oh he's doing
piggy yeah
nice give us a good fridays of pewdiepie
right
no you now oh wait
i broke you
how's it going brush my name is
pewdiepie and welcome to
friday oh my god
is that good i feel like i'm back in my
log cabin does that take
going to college hey did you see my
david dobrik impression though
should i should i do this like uh david
dobrik no word vpn
[Laughter]
vpn gets seventy percent off a
three-year
i get it that's all you gotta do so he's
doing he's doing the last thing
holy we exposed him oh my god
how do i make an ad read interesting
they're really boring i have to read the
script
laughs how do i force charisma
isn't that channel charisma on command
yeah that breaks down people like that
oh really
and if you just do that see if you got
hyper analytical i'd love to see
like a human analyst look at youtubers
and be like oh my god
they're all sociopaths what's wrong with
all of them
because it's the thing that people react
to right and then they react to it more
and more so you kind of just
that just becomes what you do because
that's the positive things people leave
on your videos being like oh i like when
it yells oh right yeah it's a lot of
energy
so then i just yell more yeah and then
you get into that
no one starts off yelling damn it no
i didn't even say that in the beginning
yes my original intro is
hello all you beautiful people out there
damn there's gotta be at least a couple
people that were going
mom take control of me
thank you for watching this video here
guys this is sponsoring this video
but anyway i don't watch david dobrik
enough to
be able to do it yeah i mean i do it
terribly wait you've already done him oh
hell yeah
review working
welcome back everybody to meme review
youtube's favorite show
have you guys bought the new merch yet
this is so sad can we hit 50 000 likes
can we get jax for dicing jesus christ
it sounds so different yeah green
pewdiepie
the people all want it the people need
it bro you never hosted the y
you never asked bro can you please host
the y
sure nice no host meme review
wait ninja did one oh all right ninjas
prides himself on his impressions as
well so this will be interesting
does he really yeah so there's a bit of
a impression uh
battle going on between each other yes
all right
it's a sub race and an impression i hope
you're watching ninja closely because
we're about to break this
down hello
i'm gloria polka okay and i know i'm not
supposed to give my own opinion but
it sounds like there's a bit of salt in
that no no
he's a gloria borga fan that's all right
you got ninja beef
ninja beefing it up now we home we
homies okay
don't try to transfer your uh i'm not
doing
your impression i think he likes doing
the gloria burger boys yeah
my name is jacksepticeye and today we
are playing
happy wheels i mean the enthusiasm is
there
yeah it's just the thing i've noticed
that everyone's impressions is that
they're afraid to get really loud uh
either they're not able to because their
neighbors will kill them or that makes
sense
they just are afraid they'll cringe at
themselves if they get that loud
there's a there's a level of of cringe
if you don't try hard enough
but you gotta fully go there you got a
full sentence
yeah zero out of ten oh damn i'll give
it a one
[Laughter]
top in the morning
try just try god if anything is cringier
when you don't try
yeah right like i'll appreciate the
effort more than anything
up in the morning yeah this is 2016
though maybe i was like that back then
we're just judging kids here this
doesn't really feel right
oh you suck nah you did good try harder
though
wait what in the world
my god oh my god it sounds good
it sounds just like recording oh my how
did you get so good
he has future youtube in here why we
eastern european
one two three
[Music]
appreciate that and he even did the one
two three
because i i count down like clap for my
sink oh i said
three two one yeah me too record yeah
so that was a behind-the-scenes effort i
wonder what goes through people's head
they're like laying on the sofa and
they're like i got nothing to do you
know what i'm gonna do just
have to go i'm gonna do it jacksepticeye
and now is the time i kind of want
someone that like actually
tries sorry jacksepticeye this is a bad
impression
because i am female not male okay
sounds like a bunch of excuses over here
top of the morning to you laddies my
name is jacksepticeye
welcome back to
i know you're irish and all and you do
have an accent but it's not the irish
accent people do
am i right it's funny how everyone who
does the accent is the like simpsons
ginger cop impression oh that's it but
whenever i actually go out and take like
ubers they're like where are you from oh
you don't sound irish
oh really so people online seem to think
i'm incredibly irish and people in real
life don't
huh everyone thinks i'm a canadian here
you should look up the only person i've
ever heard get it
half accurate is aaron oh really yeah
oh it's about to happen all right here
we go
that's actually yeah that was scared
that was pretty good he full
scented because the accent gets lost in
the middle of the energy so you don't
need the accent
but everyone focuses on doing the accent
oh my god he's giving away so much
i hope you're writing this down i'm
basically the mr beast
of youtube tits right now
okay i want to see if someone can do me
well yeah we're sitting on my
impressions
no it's well it's more like okay so now
i know wait
you did youtuber impressions oh you and
mercia
oh how's it going brothers man
that's a really good that's a good one
that's a really cute impression
2014. i'm here with pewdiepie
and i'm sick she's sick we are both
extremely bad you guys are so different
girlfriend is sick let's make an
impression video
future wise you need to shoot the video
i'm pewdiepie best youtuber 2016.
you encapsulated that in seven seconds
so beautifully
holy
that's great that's pretty good see you
are good at impressions
i just just own it
okay that's what it is
and this is my impression of
pewdiepie what do you think is going to
be i think it's going to be some solid
great
material here okay how's it going guys
my pewdiepie
[Laughter]
does your kid watch felix you're
imitating them
doctor disrespect came yeah bye
i get i get people on the street that go
like paper
but they always do like that right she
never did it like you don't say it right
get it right get the consonants
i want to see if someone can gets it
this guy gets it and today i'm going to
be doing my best
jacksepticeye impression so
jacksepticeye if you're seeing this
i am not insulting you or anything oh
i'll take it again
it's okay it's not the news i'm ready
yeah but we're still going to insult you
yeah i'm just kidding i just really
admire your work oh here we go
oh no top of the morning to you ladies
my name is jacksepticeye
and today we're playing resident evil 7.
that's my best jacksepticeye
impersonation so jackson
the guy if you see this video please be
sure to give it a thumbs up
thumbs up thumbs up because you
complimented me
the rest however no i thought it was
good he's still missing the energy
though right yeah he tried to do it
the thing about this as well is that it
takes a lot of takes a lot of courage to
put your
get out in the internet like that yeah i
wouldn't have put stuff on myself like
this
you gotta respect the balls it takes
even though my first video was an
impression video or the lack of force
sign
wait your first what sorry solid snake
oh really that's my first ever video on
my channel
so you like set off on youtube being
like all right i'm going to start
youtube
and i'm going to do impressions yeah you
know you're like you're sitting on the
couch it's like
it's time for that
has changed it's no longer
about nations ideologies ethnicity
it's an endless series of proxy battles
following mercenaries
i hope you enjoyed this video with me
jacksepticeye
and all right wait we got to devote each
other then
wait what era are we doing because
whenever you're consistent
you're okay why don't we start with 20
20 14 i don't know
of you yeah just do the whole some
pewdiepie before
how's it going my name is pewdiepie
nice how's it going see i can't even do
it that way
brows yeah it's got a fine brush
it's gotta be sound like this bra
[Laughter]
and then we have the the one you did
which one
oh i'm gonna be best youtube
ass go press
[Laughter]
that was another one yeah god changed so
much yeah and then like all the meme
review
yeah i mean what is it now what do you
do now
i don't even know nothing how did i
start this video
who am i who am i talking to us right
now oh god
your youtuber switch turned off he's
like my persona
who am i i'm empty inside okay i want i
wanna i wanna do yours
okay i wanna do yours do you wanna like
watch one just to get it
okay undertale or something okay i
appreciate that thank you
that's so fast i know damn now i get why
that's got it all
mixed up
you wanna know a secret as well i
actually make the high five sound with
my mouth every time i export it oh okay
i would always do and then just to have
the timing of it
you're right and there's a couple of
times where i forgot to put in the high
five sound effect so you can just hear
me go
i like how you're sharing all this damn
that's fast
all right this is how you do it every
time
yeah before i request you're the best
irish youtuber
you got this man
my god it's a bit too much
sorry all right i mean that is the boss
my name is i keep doing too manly
probably lonnie jacksepticeye
i can't do it way to make me sound
better bro
well if i scream too much it just goes
back tomorrow dear lads my name is
jacksepticeye
what was that leaning me take it
i tried to do it like older jackson oh
my god i mean you're not fair
i mean i can't even do that a lot of
people have been asking me to play this
game and i'm really curious about it
myself
people have asked me please
oh god i don't hate that version of
myself but like settle down man no it's
all right
just it's iconic i'm out of breath and
listening to it
i can't do this i'm cringing already all
right thank you
bro fist how do you end your videos oh
you used to do like
oh my outro used to be super long oh i
don't like it
i'm not doing it okay let's do first i
like when the other face
[Music]
wait i should do yours what was your 30
year old man yeah this is fine we're
past that push that like button in the
face like a boss
punch that like button in the face like
a boss
let's just cut this i'm done
ah children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big
pp pre-order promotion i mean